Một biểu tường quán thuộc gần sân bay tương sân nhất vừa được phát áo mới, quả cầu sây gắn hình chim lạc.
Theo Thí Kế, khu vực bòng sây lần chạc á đự kiến tranh cảnh quán chíu sáng và thay đổi biểu tượng trục tâm.
Điểm nhấn, là quả cầu đường tính năm mét đặc trên bệ cao một phy năm mét.
Thân cầu được ốc phù điều chim lạc mằng í nóc mạ đâu.
Trong khi phần để tạo hình sân ốc, tạo cảm giác, cánh chim, danh vừa lên.
Mối thầm công quá đẹp nương tương nình.
Đặc trực lời luôn, và để còn tháng của nó.
Hồi xưa đi, nơi tối tục xíu, tối hạm ràng ngắm mê.
Đời, mấy người bụi ngu ngôi.
Để quả, tổn nhất lọc hình ở biểu tưởng chim mẹ.
Để để bệ hình dài.
Chứ hình là bố địa ý nhau, chỉ hình là hình dọc hình dọc hình dọc.
Trời như vòng rất là quay.
Trời ơi.
Nói trùng người đẹp hơn, cái trước nhau.
Hình con hạc và một cái thứ 2 nóc phay nhạc dạ.
Vòng xôi lên trẻ là nước dào quân trọng của thầy phô chim mình.
Kết nối trực tửi cộng hoa, khoảng hăng thủ, trần cút khoảng,
lề vắng sĩ, bùi trị xuân và hằng lọc.
Tên gọi bắt ngùng từ khu lắng mổ chấm một bỏ đa lọc.
Nơi dân xưa gọi là chắc, một giám bột người pháp,
cắn với gây đoạn hình thằng chử viên.
Khu lắng đã được gây dời từ nhiều thập vi trước.
Vòng xôi dần thú hẹp và cắn với quả để cầu 2 mồ xanh và nó,
đừng cính khoảng 2 mẹp.
Quả để cầu phát chim lạc là một phần của những cái tạo cảnh quan khu vực
cửa nó sẽ vầy tình sự nhất với tổng bốn khoảng 2,8 mồ ti đồng.
Dự án còn cái tạo viê hè, giải phương cách, lăng càng cầu vực,
trung ký xanh và nước cấp cách đường vào nhà gà tê 2 tế bà.